good morning everyone morning
Millennials happy Monday we're so happy
to be back I think I'm over that phrase
really yeah I like it sometimes it calls
for it but sometimes I'm just I want a a
standard good morning especially on
Monday like I don't want to be annoying
you're ready annoyed just want to wish
you a good morning so she went I can't
fully turn my neck well you don't have
to you know instead of going like I have
to go with my whole body like we're just
like choose a direction you want to look
yeah I think I look right this way so
it's like in between you and the camera
okay sounds good well good morning
everyone we are so happy to be back in
studio how small is Claudia's face okay
so it's what is it Monday I had a
procedure on Wednesday honestly it's
been the longest five days ever I mean
an excruciating amount of pain but I
don't want that to speak for the
procedure because I'm like just a low
tolerance like kind of whiny baby like
so don't don't let it speak for the
whole procedure because I still
recommend it and I'm not really sure
what it's called it's somewhere between
kybella but it's just like like a like a
chin lift right yeah it's just a chin
reducer yeah achoo sir a new chin Nym
it's called new chin and so I'm spruced
and I'm swollen so this isn't even the
final result she said probably like the
utmost final result comes in three
months but probably in a week I'll see
like major I already see major
difference when I come to the car this
morning you were a small face really yes
well so I'm a lady where your little
scarf okay I was gonna wear a scarf
today because like it really feels good
to just keep it contained it hurts so
much it's so crazy that it still hurts
I know like this told me despite being
dramatic just watch out for your
microphone okay let me know if I'm
running into issues I just can't believe
you are in so much pain like that feels
so much more honestly though excute
leave it I um anyways we had a wonderful
weekend I had such a relaxing weekend so
productive made the most FOMO weekend
ever like I was in bed like a patient
but what were you missing out on Ben had
like the best time of his life on Friday
did he yeah and he was just like so many
athletes so like it's like his like
dream and like I would have been there
to just like being the cool wife you
know doing my cool wife duties and I
guess I mean it was just boys night
spent really good quality time with you
that's a good thing but like I had
modular FOMO for like the toast from
drinking and from like socializing I
haven't seen anyone besides you in like
a legit amount do you feel renewed no
well I had a very productive relaxing
weekend I knit and I do feel renewed
except my uber driver said something to
me that like really shook me what so I
was coming he picked me up I met some
friends on Saturday at a bar so like I
just like you know social is just saying
and he picked me up and then he was like
getting ready for a big night and I was
like no I'm gonna take it easy he was
like and he like gave me guilt about
like taking the night off
scribbs like god only rested for one day
like that I was resting for more than
one day and I don't know just what to
the Saturday because that's our Sabbath
but I was also gonna be resting on
Sunday and then I was like wow I dressed
a lot of days of the week like if God
only needed one day maybe I only need
one day no God is a man and in better
shape than me well that's what I said I
said well God has more strength than I
do hold on it's like but relative to the
tasks that you're doing versus what God
had to create the world God could also
be a woman - I guess it was quite a CEO
the capital H capital h-i-m
yeah kappa and i also any Cacho - pride
which was like I was having I was gonna
like literally go out and start drinking
but like I'm on so many meds that like I
been on the floor would've been great
like last year I was on the Smirnoff
float and this year Jonathan Van Ness
was on it so like if I'd been in better
shape I don't know I could have met
Jonathan man ass it's still the dream
they were all on macho happens live okay
I didn't because I need to I like Ben
was annoying me last night he went to
let me watch and I'm like I'm gonna go
home and dedicate like an entire 30
minutes to it I heard bad things about
it really only from Utah Stevens in the
Facebook group I press it and he had me
chew and like I kind of get his vibe
he's like not that he hates Andy but
like he's just like a little like
disappointed in Andy these day it's like
he's just like so jaded by it all and
like an opportunity like this we're like
it's like so mega like the Fab five and
Andy like it couldn't be better like he
didn't really take advantage of it cuz
he's just so like he's not fazed by any
of this anymore and I kind of get that
almost like he's run his course but like
I can't even say those words I've been
saying it for for a little while that
he's not really doing it for me anymore
but I do want to watch episode but I
could see how it might be like too many
cooks in the kitchen like there is so so
much personality thing as too much of a
good thing
yes so jury's out on that I still need
to watch season two of queer I okay so I
started oh my god I'm only on the second
episode but like honestly the second
episode is horrible like why the worst
thing ever happens oh my god sad okay
the episode is going amazing I'm in love
with this man oh my god stop and the
whole plan is that he wants to propose
to his I don't say anything else I just
wanted it aren't it I'll finish it enjoy
this was me the whole episode oh my god
I can't take it so cringy like truly
truly treacherous and they make up this
whole thing like I Shannon you like
Jackie I I will watch it shortly
Zak really is dying to watch it but then
we fell asleep early last night anyways
without further ado here are the fast oh
my god ow
put your scarf back on no I just
accidentally like knocked myself with my
hand why did you take your scarf off
because I think it was causing problems
with my audio and I'm just here to do a
piece on your face yes even though I
suck doesn't help put it on your face oh
my god that feels so good okay enjoy oh
my god that felt amazing
here are the fast side stories you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast just want
to let you guys know that absolutely
nothing happened this weekend and
pulling stories was like pulling teeth
today so just relax and enjoy the ride
and also like we do the show every day
and we've missed a lot of days and like
there's still nothing to talk about
honestly like not that I would ever but
like this could be a weekly show like
nothing happens in the world no but then
when it rains it pours
totally and like you know what shocks me
it's like I can't believe that there's
so many pot like most podcasts are
weekly what do you do for the rest of
the week I don't know like our podcast
is hourly and I still I mean daily daily
but like an hour a day you know and like
we still it's so hard to get it every
day
no and I'm I still feel like we don't do
enough no see so because I'm I was
getting grief from people online right
but so if people who do it once a week
what do they do all the other time they
need to have my you bird driver also
what I'm I worry this isn't becoming a
weekly show no never I am hopefully
going to be in perfect health by
Thursday for my shows in Chicago but if
you guys have suggestions for who Jackie
she co-hosts with let us know we were
thinking obviously if she's available
Darren Karp she's a crowd favorite
obviously the
shewill suspects but anybody at the box
thinking anyone you think I would jive
with will do a master posting the
toasters you guys can everyone can
comment but I was like any personal
connects to Lakota right you cheat
amateur this morning on yeah Jota is a
big fan it made me really like her she
was singing tequila with them I really
like Jota me I feel like
then he Kathy Lee brings her down I'm
gonna say it oh wow so I'm not gonna say
what I was just about to say what I was
in Kathie Lee no I didn't say like
technically you're the Hoda and I'm the
Kathie why does she said yes and like I
feel like Kathie Lee is visibly reserved
yeah it's more like quiet sorry oh my
god I really can't laugh so hard it
hurts like Danny J album but we also I
never listened to it at all this morning
I woke up so early
also I'm gonna have a lot of special
co-host throughout the summer because
the dirty jeans tour is going on I'm
having so much anxiety about it not
about like doing the shows but about
leaving the toast because I get so much
grief like when we like don't do a show
and like rightfully so because as we
always say our listeners are
shareholders like they keep this show
afloat but like I'm genuinely afraid of
a lot of our listeners well there's a
few things we can do first of all we
will have some great co-hosts and if we
don't have co-hosts I have an idea we
can do podcast over the phone but if do
I get it out but I know I can just go to
a studio and do it okay and you can just
pick up the phone
oh like we did yeah I'm Joey King she
canceled on us which was really a really
disappointing waste and so we are
supposed to reschedule but her office
managerial skills are not good it's not
her it's not any reflection on her but
just her people don't answer their email
yeah so now you know very upsetting like
I was really like like so excited no I
know and literally we announced that we
were going to record the other hour
later and then right after this the
episode I took my email and they said
they needed to reschedule fine that's
what the phrase comes from don't count
your chickens before they hatch I know I
know jobs we are I literally never ever
ever do that but I was like it's the day
of like what could go wrong and I do
want to get viewer questions no totally
and like the same thing I announce my
Boston show but like I don't have a date
and now like it's still happening but
like they're moving so slow like I'm
getting so much the grief I really need
to get off my phone once in a while and
just like look outside because the grief
is unbearable I'm so sorry
no you
cow Moos chickens before they head for
the sentencer chickens hatch and you
didn't tell anyone that they were
hatching and then everyone's like why
did you tell me no I that's alerts when
you would come out with big news people
like Bob why didn't you tell you I'm
like well cause if I did then I wouldn't
have happened and like you would have
given me [ __ ] for it like I oh wait
that's always like many times how many
big happens I never tell anyone
no anytime something's in the works like
not until it's up and Adam would I tell
I'm not not until the money is in my
bank certainly okay anyways without
further ado the past I stories you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toes speaking
of fast five chip and Joanna Gaines
welcome baby number five oh my god they
were uploading the most premium content
to social media this week not only did
they have a photographer inside the
birthing room which was really cute
chip is just like such a wordsmith with
his Twitter like he's just was saying
such few things I truly truly don't have
one who I think to say about them I only
wish them good things I couldn't be
happier for them I do think it's weird
though that there's like a pretty decent
age gap between like her fourth and her
fifth kid they took like a a big break
because they were filming the show and
when I started season one that youngest
kid was still like three well or maybe
like this was unplanned
yeah maybe I don't know I just love them
and I really can't wait for their return
to TV I still believe that it's coming
I'm not sure what capacity I don't know
if it's gonna be on the same network but
I know that it's coming
they have such a nice life everyone
could learn from them like I and by
everyone I mean like people in Hollywood
they don't have TVs that's crazy I know
like I once watched it's like Christian
documentary they did because they're
like really like have really strong
faith and it was just super interesting
like they they don't have TVs they
barely watch themselves on TV they're
kids
like don't really understand that their
parents are famous they have like the
most like normal life it must be nice
goal for me it's just like you know the
constant paparazzi it's just sometimes
it's truly unbearable I'm so sorry you
have to I mean you know it's the hustle
so I feel in best it's good life but
it's this city you know maybe if we move
to Waco we can leave a choir we could
lead a quieter life I mean I would do
anything to move to a car but we should
have moved to Waco five years ago
because since chip and Joe infiltrated
literally and the property values have
gone up that's a fact so we should have
bought like a mansion for a hundred
grand like five years and start our own
Waco you could make it Waco anywhere
totally there's chameleon small towns I
want to move to the town where Ava
bowling is from
right yeah Ava bowling is a toaster and
she comes from the smallest town ever
yeah and she has to drive 30 minutes to
go to a Sephora where she came to both
Nashville shows and she was like so
pretty it was good
she's just a rock star we love you I
love like toaster appreciation I love
talking about toasters when they don't
think I know I know I don't know what
okay I always get hurt I can't pronounce
her last name and by the way I
accidentally ended up on the morning to
his Facebook page I mean Facebook group
analytics page and you know what the
number one most active member is Lea
derringer she's a blue I know she's a
blue paint profile picture and I see she
come it's the best stuff on everything
and like she's just an active toaster
user and she's the number one the most
engaging proprietor of the week toaster
of the month also then that that may
encourage people to like start posting a
lot and it but it has to be good premium
no it's also mad intimidating to post on
the toasters like quality and quantity
oh my god posted beef bunny is singing
the toasters yesterday and I felt so bad
this girl was like oh my god my brother
met parrot Mike was sitting at so I felt
in and I was thinking once I saw it I'm
like wow she looks really bad Paris
Hilton it was not Paris 300 comments
like sweetie that's not it was so funny
that was so funny it didn't look like
her that was so it was like more premium
than if she had actually read whatever
Silvan and it's like one of my favorite
toasts post and member posts in it thank
you so much I think my favorite types of
chose posts are ones that involve like
people's boyfriends or husbands because
like first of all every toaster has like
the hottest boyfriend brother a husband
like every time there's a boy involved
they're incredibly hot and they love the
toast
they love the choice and I love when
they talk about like your online friends
like and that they kept like why do you
talk like those girls on well TV but it
depends how you watch it yeah well I
guess when you stream this to your
television we're on TV no no TV of the
new age totally depends who you're
talking to a media scholar
we're TV an old person no we're web
we're iCarly yeah like whenever older
people like what channels or show like
it's digital whatever
one day it's on IG TV ever heard of it
oh my god we're gonna start uploading
we're gonna figure it out either if
today's episode can't make it then
tomorrow we're just gonna record
vertical mode anyways we'll be on IPTV
tomorrow so stay tuned people who are
like check out my IG t IG TV channel I
can they make it sound like they're on
TV you know totally and also I can't not
say HGTV like it's just that they had it
first
I agree I just I I G can't keep up okay
so like I know that it's supposed to be
an hour every video I'm seeing is like a
minute but like it's like we needed a
place for like a minute videos that's
not on your main feed but also not
cutting it up every 15 seconds you know
yeah I don't know I don't know and they
can't figure like I just said it
could've been a way to merge AG TV you
see it almost said HD and stories I
guess but stories aren't great the way
they are don't leave them please I
understand the need for like a video
platform on Instagram but like why why
do they help you everything they're
trying to take down everyone this is
their attack on YouTube I don't think
it's gonna work maybe their YouTube is
way too strong totally okay anyways I'm
really happy for the game the whole
games clan next up just an update on our
Friday story but Game of Thrones stars
Kit Harington and Rosa that's like got
married did you see the blood no so the
blind basically said they couldn't not
invite emilia clarke because it would
have been too obvious like everyone was
there like even Robb Stark was there and
he hasn't been on the show since season
two but because of their love triangle
they couldn't not invite her because it
would have been too obvious but there
really is a very strong love triangle
between Rosslyn he grid you know nothing
Jon Snow and Dany Targaryen oh my god
that's crazy its life imitates art you
guys I know but she walked in there like
she owned the place pictures of her
smiling let's talk about those pictures
okay
well talk about how it was literally
Anna Palace she wore like a glowing
sleeved gown everyone was wearing kilts
everyone he was wearing an English tuck
I know and Maisie Williams were jumpsuit
and so everybody was going to the club
yep I'm so confused by their outfits
I mean I don't know I just feel like
they're all just different like and
march to the beat of their own drum
speaking of the Emilia Clarke she looked
drunk like she was having a good time
not in the bed right lecture I only saw
the pictures of her walking in with
Peter Dinklage behind her yeah me too
okay whoever like the paparazzi was on
that way and then I was gonna say like
it was photographed like the Royal
Wedding totally have getting images
there I don't or like did they're
professional photographers tell them to
just Jared and
immediately after I think like a wedding
at a palace like palaces like public
property I think no it was so it was
weird like I was so grateful for the
pictures and she looked so beautiful but
I just didn't understand but they could
have acted like Emilia couldn't couldn't
make it I was thinking like they could
have done it more like she wouldn't be
there then people be like where was
Millie and then she would've left like
an Instagram comment like wish I could
have been there you know I wish like if
it were me if I were real Leslie like
I'd rather her not be there and totally
regulate then her be there and really
the uncomfortable also I just like to
say for the first time ever like even
since the morning be I'm not wearing
makeup on them on the show today I've
never knocked on that Wow honest I just
could it hurts too much to put it on
honestly we're so far away it looks the
same I can see myself literally an hour
every morning literally are you
restlessly literally literally no okay
also I'm gonna see some controversial I
do not like her hair I know it's show me
to say like not a nice things to have
people on their wedding day I'll make it
Marco but like sorry when your celebrity
people send me things about me on my way
and my wedding really what they say I
don't know I thought she looked very
nice and very herself which is all you
can really ask I hate when what I really
don't like is when people look like a
different person on their wedding day
and it's like that's not who you're
marrying
also I just can't believe like he
married a wildling no I can't believe he
married like someone from Game of
Thrones I know it's so weird cuz he's
like so eligible and that it was his
like long time like it was a long time
ago and he it was his like rule it
wasn't you know just Santa like you
couldn't marry him if he imagined he was
marrying Sansa no totally he couldn't be
yet but she's too tall for him right but
like they brother and sister and it's
really small he's so cute though no he's
hot as hell but he's small well maybe
she's smart too honestly like I had
completely forgotten about Robb Stark
until I saw a picture of him and I
remember being so in love with him when
he was on the show and literally he is
so hot he I want to say he's hotter than
Kit Harington okay Harrington like tbh s
and not that hot he's really short and
asked earlier
no rap started like two classically
good-looking it's like no but like he
was a little character he was so robbed
on that show literally like in
retrospect he probably thought he was
gonna have the role of a lifetime thank
you by the way sorry no Oh spoiler alert
if you don't watch me boring if you do
and like you're not caught up sorry but
even if you don't watching you're gonna
watch like you don't even know who
you're talking about we're not you're
not gonna remember or like Ned Stark
being like going home be like you guys
I'm gonna be patriarch of this of a show
of a show that's gonna have ten seasons
totally that for you Ned by right 2019
is really close like member when we had
said season eights coming in 2019 like
it's so long ago it's really and I'm
just so happy for all the like basic
[ __ ] on Instagram I couldn't get over
it oh my god are we caps up Game of
Thrones
I can't wait to bring them back I just
but I can wait for everyone being like
tense never like a picture of them like
photoshopped on the Iron Throne like you
know nothing chance now I can't deal
with basically but just to watch Game of
Thrones it's horrible
that's up this is Iron Throne I really
want to start like some beef today start
beef Lee oh my god please don't I know I
couldn't him I don't have the story the
beef was enough oh my god so I'm we
watching Sex in the City and I hadn't
discovery uh-huh okay do you know I told
you this early so you remember when
Samantha Seaton richer and she can't get
him to commit and that calm is said
she's always trying to get him written
up in page six writes up that he was
seen with Cece Jones yeah or Billy Jones
sorry yes yeah so his name is JJ and
he's like this like gossip like older
man columnist and I'm pretty sure I mean
there's literally no evidence of this I
didn't even look it up but I think he
was like supposed to be portraying AJ
Benza
I think what makes you think that um his
name is JJ first of all okay and which
is like more than enough pretty and they
have like the same vibe a of like the
same like New York and they're like
they're like dark-haired men and they're
like gossip columnist and yeah well
that's prestigious as hell yeah even
though it's the worst show of all time
like that's pretty oh my god I'm so I'm
so in it now she just she broke up with
a tin and like I can't say this enough
times like every guy she gets is not
her oh my god I just read that wrong
sorry she's not good enough for any
other guy she gets I just finished the
episode where she needs a loan and
obviously she has to get what she makes
like 10 cents a week and buys a kitten
heels and like she does all the math
that she'd spent $50,000 on shoes and
all she needs is 30,000 to make a down
payment so if she'd like cut back on she
would have been able to do the down
payment and she's giving Charlotte so
much grief for not speaking up and
offering her the money even though she
wouldn't have taken it even though she
ended up taking it and then she goes too
big for money like Charlotte said it
perfectly your financial mess is not my
problem I couldn't agree with anyone and
like her shaming her into giving her the
ring that was towards her but I was
horrible that wasn't by the way it's
more like I learned to hate to show the
more I realize everyone hates the show I
just saw an article in the cut that was
like we've ranked every episode of the
deeply problematic series Sex in the
City like everyone agrees that it's like
a very property they think it's
problematic for the same reasons we
think yes that is tender and carrie
who's the so self arable character so
selfish a two-year-old baby like she is
in a fury a tooth licker
yeah and I can't decide if I hate her
you couldn't help it wonder do you hate
her I couldn't help but wonder is it
Sarah Jessica Parker that I hate or
Carrie Bradshaw or both it's both yeah
she made Carrie terrible but like carrot
what Carrie says and does is annoying
the way that Sarah Jessica Parker
portrays it is even more annoying and
like I don't think that Candace Bushnell
used to like her teeth and no not at all
I can't also wait someone has a question
oh please watch Carrie Diaries I watched
it it's amazing it's literally better
than sex in the city and there's only
two seasons there's only two seasons
miyamoto are obsessed with it and that's
another thing by the show she never
talks about herself we don't mean any of
their parents there's like they're all
week like Miranda's mom passes away one
episode they talk about their family we
meet Charlotte's brother okay like I
mean something eight seasons we don't
even know where Carrie's from no we know
that her dad abandoned her mom right but
we don't know where she's where she grew
up
and why she saw in her diary she's from
like Connecticut New Castle no but she
says she comes she comes into the city a
lot right well she doesn't internship
right but she never talked about when I
was young in the city no totally like
the way she talks about New York I could
die I could die
it's
makes me wanna move okay anyways next
story really they kind of sad something
that we haven't been covering a lot but
she's in the news again so I figured we
would touch on it but Heather Locklear
has been arrested again for battery of a
police officer and an EMT just goes on
with her a lot only a couple days after
Heather Locklear was released from a
three day psychiatric hold the actress
was arrested for battery on a police
officer police took Locklear into
custody at her home shortly before
midnight Sunday and booked her for two
counts of misdemeanor battery upon an
officer and emergency personnel page six
confirmed this is her second arrest for
battery of Deputies police originally
arrived at Locklear's home to answer a
disturbance call from a family member
according to TMZ the Melrose Place star
reportedly was intoxicated and agitated
and punched an officer who attempted to
separate her from her family while
paramedics put her on the gurney
Locklear kicked an EMT
she was pretty transported to a hospital
for a valley evaluation and then taken
to jail where she was booked she's being
held on $20,000 bail okay it's almost
like she did that movie with Hilary Duff
and everything went downhill after that
even though that maybe is amazing I know
but I feel because she literally
catfishes her mom it's like so [ __ ] up
no it's so [ __ ] up
speaking of catfished Nev is back I know
I was gonna put that as a story but I
just didn't want to talk about him no
totally I can't stand him like honestly
he unfollowed me on Instagram years ago
and like it's the best thing he ever did
I literally hate him that's well start
beef with today like literally Nev come
for me kind of spoon umass okay um I
feel really badly for Heather walk there
okay like she's going through a lot and
I feel like she's like seen a lot you
know what I mean yeah and he's like a
Charlie Sheen victim yeah even though I
don't really know what he does but he's
just like being in his presence is it's
like amazing yeah she was on dying to
see though I didn't realize that it says
the dynasty actress was placed in a
psychiatric have said the Oscar
award-winning perfect man actress cuz
that's literally the best show oh my god
a big is in it Chris Noth plays the
perfect man oh my god I totally forgot
about that that's because I feel like
he's literally in nothing except that
but he's also in I'm julianna margulies
show I'm sorry but the premise is just
too weird for that movie no no she
literally was like falling in love with
her mom it's just cuz her mom was
falling in love with her daughter
incest no one talks about that the
deeply problematic plot of the perfect
man
it's disgusting it really who plays like
her best friend in high school someone
that we know now I feel like it's Gordo
no I feel like it's Miranda I mean they
give off that vibe yeah yeah an
unimportant friend wait I need to look
it up anyways but I couldn't
confirmation she was in the old dynasty
yeah no I'm sure she was I I didn't mean
I said I want to watch all fantasy
though I think would give me more
appreciation for the new dice when she
falls in love but this movie came out in
2005 oh it's um I'll give you a clue
okay Oh charades
okay okay no no no I think I think you
don't know you don't know wait hold on
we were just quoting her but I can't
remember what we were courting so I'll
just do an obvious one they don't
oh wait oh okay I think I know who it is
because we know Lord neither oh [ __ ]
because we know neither you Aang come on
okay okay wait if anyone were to be so
hungry Claire
make sure that I'm doing this right oh
okay well the guy that place like the
guy she falls in love is has been
fighting I know and he's from AZ Joanne
yes because we know needle and she kind
of looks like Miranda vibes yeah sex I
said no Elizabeth water I thought it was
someone else but you know I chill do
know but the guy who plays her love
interest is Ben Feldman who's from Drop
Dead Diva who plays a guardian angel you
either you probably saw in the first
episode that you watched and didn't like
can you believe guys jack live tonight
episodes and I couldn't believe what I
was watching
I'm sorry it's the greatest show there's
a lot of dough annoying she's amazing
she's everything no annoying and you
know what the way she talks makes me
feel bad for people who listen to us
like that's why she's great excuse me
your honor him yeah she's oh man I can't
believe you don't like that Joe like
that is what's wrong with you you're
missing a piece of your soul Claudia no
it's the best show she's so cute
Mandarin I love her oh my god I can't
believe nak you and she's not an earring
and that's the throwing Dee right no
she's not so Wonder
so in such a heartfelt good message show
I don't know I'd really like trash no
and by the way the premise of it makes
no sense like how she's in it's a show
woman's mind she has her mind and you
know it doesn't make sense that both you
am one I totally agree
that's true but like it wouldn't make
sense okay this next story is from last
week or the end of last week but I
decided to bring it up because I watched
the proposal last night oh my god I
never was enough to watch it it's
hilarious and like it's not even
hilarious like I felt like I was walking
like an SNL parody of a show like I
can't believe that this is on TV and
primetime not well they had to pull the
second episode because of some
allegations right so ABC proposal
episode pulled after a woman accuses
contestant of facilitating her sexual
assault so this is really crazy this set
the preview for the second episode which
is supposed to be on tonight exactly and
a Milwaukee woman named Erica de neige
mesh key accuse show contestant Michael
J Friday of setting her up to be
sexually assaulted in early November so
basically the story goes that she
matched with him on a dating app he
invited her over to like his apartment
Lobby complex like game room situation
and when she got there there were like
two men him he was there and also like
two men were there and he left and like
what yet and ain't you heard of a past
like that like the last thing you're
gonna do was go on TV right that's crazy
territory I'm sure that she's like
considering this seem to be like a whole
orchestrated thing like I doubt she was
though the first water yeah so I'm
really glad that they took swift action
and cancelled the episode okay but we're
the police now like I love a great get
canceled all that's up like where's the
place right because this is a crime
crime um I don't know but two people
really got engaged shot on the first
episode and honestly they're still
together they are yeah well from the
minute she walked down I was like she's
gonna win bris well she was the only one
who had confidence she walked out me she
was so excited to be there everyone else
had posture like this I would too
ideally awkward no it was horrible
they're walking around like littles
they're walking around amazing suits
like beauty contestants but they're like
slumped and like so insecure it's it's
so painful and he like they literally
got engaged before they even ever kissed
it was so weird so but I actually feel
like they were really good
I'm really happy for them I saw it from
a mile away also the other like the like
the crop of women it was a premium
what's not premium like they're not even
like bachelor rejects like they're
they're like are you the one rejects
anything maybe it was very strange I
don't know what I watched I don't know
if I show love island I've heard that I
have to watch our that I was oh good I
see people a lot of tweeting it all the
time like what channel is it on it's
like MTV UK you surely I think it's not
here and so you would have to watch it
online which is just too far so many
work to go do for a new show you know
like if I'd love to the show my pocket
is full my docket is Stoffel I'm still
watching madman I'm trying to slow down
because it's like I want to space it out
that's how I feel about Blue Bloods okay
I'm on season seven of the buds I know
you don't want you're still watching who
buys I got just he's in pipes so quickly
and then I was like I love this show I'm
need to chill I took a majora cand now
I'm like picking back up but like I
really enjoy it it's like so nice to
have something just to watch and it's
like I see you but better and Jamie and
Eddie finally kiss and they mean they
Pitt's before but like they were just
like we like each other and I was just
like thank God like it's just so
beautiful and Vanessa who plays Eddie
follows me on Instagram and one time her
and Jamie sent me a video and the audio
wasn't working like I wanted to die but
he was something along the lines that
they like my interpretive dance that's
amazing yeah that's the problem with
binging a show cuz when you're in it you
just want to know what happens next you
keep watching but then when you're done
you over you wish for the days when you
didn't know what was gonna happen so now
that I'm in it right now I'm like do I
speed through and find out what happens
or do i well I wish for this moment back
exactly so I'm trying to slow down but
it's love island is apparently on Hulu
that makes it easier I'm not going on it
does but I don't use Hulu I don't know
why maybe I got someone to count
I got someone's password I'm sure I
could get one and it's there when I need
it like because sometimes they have like
a Bravo show labeled Bravo shows like
season 1 Roni but other than that I
truly don't see the point I don't know I
like Amazon Prime these days and if I
want something badly enough I'll pay for
it
ya know I mean like if you love a show
you should support it
subscribe to our patreon at the morning
just great plug sister okay anyways
justice was served for the proposal
thank God so but that was supposed to be
one woman and ten men so I hope
tonight's episode is still one woman in
ten men because last week was one man in
ten women got a cup you know that's a
bachelorette proposal proposed that they
the final story oh yeah visit - story
Kim Kardashian breaking news says she's
done with selfies quote I don't really
like them
I kind of agree I kind of agree - I
really feel bad selfie in like years and
it's just like it's not really even
people are like so hip to all the tricks
down they can become from a high angle
like people know you're just tunnel up
skinny like high angle is just way to
MySpace there's a couple tricks
first of all standing in front of a
window or using a Lumi yes then there's
facetune yes naturally excites it's just
like I'm so with Kim she she hit the
nail on the head
my thing is I don't feel like she's done
with selfies like I feel like she's
always posting southeast oh I mean she
literally released a book do you
remember that yeah I want to get it I
saw someone had it at a party and I was
like sitting on the couch reading it and
you know what she did which is truly
brilliant in the middle there's like
seven nude photos of her because like
the week that her book was supposed to
be released she like heard from her
lawyer that someone had hacked her
iCloud and gotten seven nude photos so
instead of negotiating with them she
released them herself that's she said
she's really a businesswoman genius
businesswoman she knows anyways in an
interview with ITV's this morning not to
be confused with IG TV oh I'm sure
they're pissed whoever ITV is what is a
I don't know but somewhere that Kim
Kardashian goes so I'm sure they're
important maybe it's international it's
definitely it's definitely international
TV kardashian-west revealed the sudden
change in her photo taking ways and
explain that the reason for this
surprising move is because she wants to
be more present in her everyday life
quote I don't take selfies anymore I
don't really like them I just it's not
all about sitting there taking selfies I
just like to live there in real life I
don't mind pictures but it was not on my
phone like I used to
brilliant like she said Paris was meant
to happen to her and she's so happy that
her kids get to grow up with this
version of her as a mom as her know
she's very funny as hell she's doing
everything the cheese city which I'm
like so here for Abid overdone like
you're not
no I get what she means like selfies
aren't cool anymore no I get what she
means too and like honestly I've scaled
back so much on storying mostly because
like I love snapchat now on Instagram I
feel like it's more about like pretty
stuff not so much like I agree saw and
I'm talking my views are double when I
have like half the amount of view of the
stories which is like so sad cuz like I
love to just story the [ __ ] out of my
life but like I when I love stories I
don't use volumes so when I do my own
stories I rarely do anything that
requires volume anyways it's made me
like just storing less which is fine
it's just a different I think we're all
scaling back a little bit which I'm
definitely here for yeah but I'm also
here for posting whatever the [ __ ] you
want to post once it was it you want I'm
so not here to like judge other people's
like social media lies like just do what
you want I'm so done with like the older
generation like passing dispersions on
us do you know what I mean
what it's like despair is it truly get a
spoon in my ass like these Millennials
they're always in their phones like
we're not just doing nothing like we're
building brands we're making money like
[ __ ] off like I'm just I'm truly I'm
about to round like I'm just so done
with like people like having just like-
like and condescending things to say
about like a people who like have jobs
on the internet and be just like
Millennials in general oh there's
Millennials like they talk too fast
others money I was like they're always
on their phone they can't get their
heads on their ass like you can't get
your head out of your ass [ __ ] get a
spoon and eat it okay I feel like you're
referring to something specific I know
I'm not I'm Who am I like these people
like on TV like the local news like it's
you're smart it's your child smartphone
announcing their brain like [ __ ] off
local news anchor know who came on my
local news last night who shad a
dangerous I wasn't referring to her oh
my god sorry I must clarify there was
anyone to throw Shaddai it would be
shudder of course I went through ash a
day I would I would list I would
literally be like yeah throw that chug
I would I would take her Sharda with a
grain of salt I love her me so co-host
she'll be perfect
she's you think our morning show
coincides with our morning show no cuz
hers it's like morning and ours is like
morning brunch yeah
hardcore brunch yeah hearses breakfast
stars this brunch since we have some
extra time let's do something we did we
haven't done in a while let's take some
questions I'm watching on Facebook what
are you watching on am i watching on
Facebook okay so flood Facebook with
some questions about whatever you want
and what time is it it's 11:00 okay look
ten minutes okay look six questions
oh wait okay few many questions for me
while we wait for questions I have to
ask you a question okay
no just we're waiting for questions so
would you what so got today what's the
inspiration well the inspiration is I
wanted to wear this dress because it's
so cute they didn't want my arms to be
out in the back then I'd just be
self-conscious no show so I was gonna
wear a leather jacket but it's June so I
wore this it's actually really nice
temperature in the studio today let me
see my outfits really cute I'm gonna
stand up please this is my Kim Possible
dress Kim Possible if you want to reach
me if you want to page me it's okay
whenever you need me mam a comment if
you want to reach me okay can you guys
get Fallon from dynasty on the show we
will try we have a personal connection
to her yet but I don't feel like she's
in New York a lot no I think she's like
a film in Atlanta she lives in LA so
yeah she's definitely not in New York a
lot
did you see Ashley from southern terms
it's a story I saw I don't really get it
I don't indulge psyche like mentally
unstable people I actually feel bad for
her and yeah I'm over it and just wait
for the reunion thank you
who's the biggest person that ever
canceled on the show that you never
revealed that cancelled on the show we
never cancelled but we did get an email
from Kim's publicist that was cool
yeah but know someone who no one never
canceled that chad johnson didn't show
up yeah and I think that's about it um
everyone's asking about Ashley from
southern charm are you going to Taylor
Swift that MetLife okay yeah I am too
I'm one of the 29 I mean no no that's
what's the third show twice
whatever I'm going oh you are I'm making
beggar with me Oh fine and I'm still
working on getting in through
I believe I'm going on xx unburied so
that means I'm wearing the 22nd
I'm literally counting down the days
till Friday because I'm going to the
most exciting concert of my life oh my
god you know I'm trying to get weight
you're going to the drugs beach 1 no I'm
going to rascal sorry Jersey so they're
also gonna be at Jones Beach on July 6
the 6th
I was looking this morning and I'm try
to get Ben to drive me okay if you guys
go and we have a fun time Friday which I
know I'm going to yell me okay
cuz it's an hour and a half it's really
truly in the middle of the Hamptons in
the city I'm like Rascal Flatts and Dan
and che
I know by the my you know was also there
a little bit child yes they are over
there are in Jones Beach it's Lady
Antebellum Little Big Town Brad Paisley
Rascal Flatts easy to festival I don't
know it's five acts wait that's so weird
I don't that sounds like a fun day
though yeah and you know what like look
at all the show times though because I
really would only want to dance a rascal
box no but it's good a little big town
center cuz we're gonna need to get like
food in the bathroom if we join a patron
can we see the original episodes so I
believe when you join patron you get
access to the past three episodes right
yes and they're good so it's worth it
also um favorite song from the damaja
album a lot I love my side of the fence
and island time and I still think alone
together is like so wondering I think
auto myself is still my god okay I'm
making headway
so I've realized that like where my core
fans are are the wives and girlfriends
of country music stars Shea's wife
follows we have how to rock this morning
stay tuned so now we have to go ask her
she's let me go and teach oh yeah of
course public I just father I can't be
like a first month so general day one
any info on the production assistant
position you mentioned on the podcast
info is that it's fun it's a great job
you should apply yeah I think you'll
have a good time
people keep asking my Joey King I guess
you tuned in marry late to the show she
lost her voice last week or was sick and
we are rescheduling stay tuned I just
started Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
season one does everybody hate Camilla
just me you hate her but then like just
keep watching yeah you need her in a
moment but like now looking back like
she was truly everything we needed as a
cast mate and more
Jackie has what in clinic she doesn't
talk about I'm gonna
you should I would love to what's your
go-to drink that you water uh it's glass
of Sancerre
but it's so lame you know what it's Who
I am and I'm glad that I'm in tune with
what's necessary as I grow older did you
pick a wedding date yes for the most
part for the most part I would say 90%
sure who's the least professional famous
person you've met or been near ooh well
I mean like professional is a stranger
because they're celebrities we deal with
now like a lot of them are reality stars
they don't need to be professional
they're just normally celebrities what
constitutes professional your job is to
be famous I feel like people celebrities
who are professional think they're divas
and they have other people handle [ __ ]
for them whereas other people just walk
in here come with their best friend and
do the show honestly you know who's
really unprofessional
Mason Ramsey no I'm totally kidding you
know who was an unprofessional but who
scared me a lot Kate Chastain from below
Jack she was like she was really
intimidating yeah and like watch a show
and I was here yeah she's a scary [ __ ]
yeah but good for her did you see that
Shep shotgunned a beer with Dave girl
from the Foo Fighters that was really
cool
no I didn't did you see that he's like
with the Queen what he's in the youth
with the Foo Fighters in the UK and he
went to like all these royal events and
won that the Queen was beggin there
he didn't say on his Instagram that's so
crazy
can we get to Lila belt as a co-host she
likes all of one just posts I would love
to but I don't think she'd be into it I
know they're gonna work on co-hosting
they're an organ we're gone or worgen
it's very friend Oh first of all some
someone who might have an inside scoop
at Jones Beach that every band plays for
an hour okay that's helpful
that's like not enough I could go to a
rascal factor concert for four hours I
could listen to like the whole Jenin
shade both albums being just played and
like a few singles mean first novel yeah
would you have the cast if she has to
key back on the show of course they
looked so cute for probably because he
looked so cute um Juliet looks you mean
her I know so Chloe looks so good like
all their makeup looks so good
no I Jackie I literally was like a
living for the premium content they were
serving on Instagram who's your favorite
housewife of all time it goes back and
forth cutting of the top three
LuAnn Lisa Rinna Erika Jayne yeah
I think mines Erika Jayne Lisa Rinna is
like she just became one of my favorites
so jury's still out on her and my
favorites Erika Jayne did you see the
banner from house they wrenched over the
weekend it looked like tails trekker was
there and like I wanted to know I know
look they they'll stay there and feather
I stopped seeing Ariana finally had
their birthday I know and they looked
amazing and they're twins they're twins
and they looked so gorgeous
and like skinny and beautiful like it
pains me to say because I think Ariana
like literally despises us but she
looked gorgeous yeah
wait sorry sorry anyway I'm looking into
camp toast okay what is your favorite
subgroup oh that's a great question
probably toast after dark mine has just
recently become gypsy toasters
they're insane the videos they share are
so funny I feel like we're gonna be
liable like if someone dies because
we're just encouraging like drinking but
it's premium tipsy testers I had was
suggested I'm sorry I'm behind and silky
no how's it going he was off all weekend
because like you know you gotta live but
he's back on this morning and yes he is
okay that was fun I love answering
questions it's like so self-indulgent
it's like what's better than that let's
do some housekeeping announcements my
website is down and I don't know how to
fix it so if you want to get tickets to
my girl with no jobs dirty jeans tour go
to my Instagram highlights there are
spikes everywhere and also just like DME
and I'll send a link also I'll see you
in Chicago on Thursday Friday and
Saturday I'm really excited Chicago
isn't underrated say I've never been to
Chicago
I've only been twice for the Steve
Harvey Show but twice is a lot but like
they fly you in and out like I've never
really gotten to experience them there's
four days now you should go to
Lollapalooza I'm going to a Cubs game
yeah Osler got me tickets I have to
respond to her you know I don't know
it's just yeah I'm very excited even
though is it hot or cold there I think
it's like New York temperature then it's
just windier that's why they called what
is it I gotta go to the beam oh my god
and you gotta have none of their
deep-dish pizza
I gotta flip maybe your palates more to
find that I'm like I don't like to eat
fish but I probably make deep ditch
cookie like pie and that I could be in
for yeah I had the most amazing cake
yesterday for Ben's dad's birthday like
brought it from just the grocery store
it was kind
it was screw suri bakery like like a
regular just vanilla cake but it was
definitely from a box but it was
unbelievable it sounds so good and what
about you any housekeeping announcements
any housekeeping balance mints you can
always tell me in jackieo problems I
actually have a bit of premium content
coming out later today and yeah I'm
gonna start a master post in the tow
service for co-host suggestions please
and we'll take you from there you guys
may be able to switch things up I don't
know what that will look like but maybe
we'll just like get crazy what does that
mean I don't know what every go a panel
an evening show oh well it's been an
absolute pleasure hanging out with you
thank you for being a toaster the
morning toast is the Millennial morning
show we go by Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on Facebook in
YouTube we live stream there so make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube and
you like us on facebook or you should
join the morning shows there's Facebook
group it is a premium AF but if you're a
commuter don't have time to watch we
also are available as podcast so make
sure you check out the morning to us
podcast leave us five stars talk about
how beautiful we are
how wonderful the show is anything you
can really think of I didn't I don't
discourage anything positive thank you
so much for hanging out i'm claudia a
girl with no job
I'm Jackie I'll show you Jackie Oh
problems have a great treacherous Monday
you